hey youtubers is Charlie so I'm going to
explain what's going on with this Batman
Ben Affleck news he's not going to
direct he's still doing the movie though
there's a lot of craziness that's
happening but just as a giant aspirin
pill to make everyone feel better I will
be doing a new flash ring giveaway
tonight with my flash video so be sure
to subscribe to get that and click that
Bell to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything I'll start with the facts first
then I'll talk about the rumors and then
I'll talk a little bit about Gotham at
the end of this because they just did
some big Joker stuff so if you don't
know the actual statement that Ben
Affleck release says there are certain
characters who hold a special place in
the hearts of millions just
acknowledging the fandom Batman is one
of the most popular comic book
characters of all time he goes on
performing this role demands focus
passion in the very best performance
that I can give it has become clear that
I cannot do both jobs talking about
acting directing and writing the script
to the level that they require now when
he says both jobs he's actually doing
three jobs so if you didn't know
previously he was writing the movie with
Jeff John he was directing it and he was
acting in it there are very few actors
that can actually pull that off Mel
Gibson doing Braveheart is a really good
example of that that took a long time to
make and if you want to see a Batman
movie in the next 10 years then that
requires getting some help so that's why
Ben Affleck is making this statement he
says I've decided to find a partner in a
director who will collaborate with me on
this massive film I am still in this and
we are making it but we are currently
looking for a director and I'll explain
who they're looking for right now and
then he just reiterates that he's
looking forward to this he's committed
to it bringing it to the fans of the
world so basically he's saying that he's
getting super burnt out trying to do
everything that you could possibly do
like literally doing every single job so
he's getting a little bit of help to
come in I know there are a lot of rumors
so I'll address those two in a second
but the director who's at like the top
of the list right now the most likely
candidate is Matt Reeves the person who
did more of the Planet of the Apes so
they're looking for people that can do
really big tentpole films like this
without letting the characters get lost
in the mix so what's happening here
is that Ben Affleck still has control of
the project so he's looking for someone
to collaborate with and a lot of people
are like hey what about David Fincher
why can't we get him what about George
Miller he makes amazing movies there was
a Justice League movie that he was going
to make a long time ago before it fell
through but it is amazing as some of
those directors are it's a lot like the
story of Edgar Wright's version of
ant-man if you remember way back Edgar
Wright had been hired to do the ant-man
movie for Marvel they teased it several
years ago there was some test footage
that was released and then what ended up
happening is is that he had trouble
fitting it into Kevin Feige version of
what he was looking for in a Marvel film
so in the last couple of years Marvel
has really reached out to talented
up-and-coming directors but it's still
very much Kevin Feige vision so Ben
Affleck and Geoff Johns had this really
amazing vision for Batman and what
they're going to do is try to find a
director that can help them make their
version of Batman not somebody who will
come in and say I'm going to do it my
way or I'm not going to do it at all and
that's exactly who David Fincher is like
they're only going to make the version
of the movie
that they want to make they're not going
to make somebody else's movie and
because it's Batman it's going to be
Geoff Johns and Ben Affleck's film so
they're looking for a partner they're
not looking for someone to make the film
by themselves so going back to the
ant-man movie everybody freaked out when
Edgar Wright walk from the project
they're like oh my god ant-man is dead
we're never going to see it but then
they hired Peyton Reed and everyone's
like who is this guy we've never heard
of it he's never done a big movie like
this in the movie turned out great like
we're going to get the sequel to that
ant-man and the loss relatively soon in
phase 3 so this Batman stuff is just one
of those situations where it sounds like
there's a lot of crazy drama that's
being heightened behind the scenes but
really it's just Ben Affleck trying not
to burn himself out before he actually
has to act as Batman a lot of you are
also asking about the stuff that Ben
Affleck was saying last month like if
the script isn't good then I'm not going
to do it and it seems like he's not
doing it now in terms of directing like
he's still acting at it but what that
actually means is that it takes him a
long time to write his scripts it took
him a long time to make Argo it took him
a long time to make live by night he
acted and directed
both of those movies so like I said at
the beginning of this if you want to see
a Batman movie in the next 10 years you
have to bring in some people to help
move things along because any one person
can only do one or two things really
really well at the same time so they
don't want to wind up with like half of
a good Batman movie they want a really
awesome Batman movie so now that Ben
Affleck doesn't have to worry about
directing he can just focus on finishing
the script and delivering a really
amazing performance so the only thing
that's happening here is that he's just
not doing every single possible job that
you could possibly do the really good
thing that that points to is that the
studio wants to start shooting the movie
in the next couple of months if you
remember it was rumored that they were
going to release it sometime during 2018
now that could always get pushed to 2019
because it typically takes about 18
months after they start shooting to
actually release a movie now that's just
like an average number so you can see
why the studio wants to start shooting
the movie sometime this year because at
the current pace Ben Affleck probably
won't finish getting ready till almost
the end of the year meaning the movie
would get pushed even further so really
that's all that's going on is there any
really big announcements about the
directors that they hire I'm assuming
that it's probably going to be the War
of the Planet of the Apes person usually
when they say someone's at the top of
their list it's because they're
finalizing contracts before they
actually start doing work on the movie
the other big rumor I know a lot of you
probably heard about this is it because
live by night didn't perform the way the
studio wanted to did Ben Affleck is just
sort of rethinking the way he approaches
projects that just goes back to the idea
of trying to do everything yourself and
working on multiple projects at the same
time which is kind of what he's been
doing so I think the studio is just like
there's too much stuff that you're
trying to do so let's just have you do
the really important stuff we'll bring
in a little bit of help and everything
will be great
so I don't think the studio pushed them
out I think he just saw that he was
going to go crazy if he tried to do
every single thing himself and he didn't
want to have like a mental breakdown
even though that would be in keeping
with Batman's character Batman goes
pretty crazy every once in a while but
that's really all that's going on with
it
it just sounds like it's worse than it
actually is because of all the political
stuff that's happening like if you go on
social media so many people are
complaining about stuff that's happening
in real life right now that it's hard to
tell what's going on with the really fun
stuff that you would normally be
spending your time thinking about so I
highly recommend that you watch the
flash tonight it will make you totally
feel better about life humanity in
general gypsies coming on I'll be doing
a video for it later but a lot of you
were also asking about Gotham that was
the video that I was originally going to
make before this huge Ben Affleck news
dropped they introduced a more new 52
version of the Joker than we've seen
before
you on hell of you on
you too shall be reborn you don't want
to miss what happens next
what do you say Bruce wanna have some
fun before the main event
let's turn that frown upside down
you want to kill someone let's get on
with it telly in the night with a bang
or better yet I'm home ready not really
they see kids don't them had no hero
Jerome went full Joker they had some
nice nods to the killing joke with Bruce
Wayne here and he even did some very
Batman things there like slowly inching
him towards his Batman persona he's
still a very young version of the
character but if you guys have any
requests for DC movie videos just leave
them in the comments below there's a lot
of stuff that's going to be happening
with Wonder Woman in the next couple of
months but because the movie doesn't
come out till June they haven't started
their campaign yet usually when
campaigns are going on that's when you
see all the footage dropping everywhere
when you see them making all this noise
so that will start happening really soon
so hopefully everybody chills out a
little bit we're gonna have a new
episode of the flash tonight I'll post
my videos later there'll be a new round
of the flash ring giveaway
it'll be great well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
how the flash can be savage cars is here
and you can click here or what's going
on with the Aquaman music which is all
good news thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
in the next video